-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got a full audience.
I'm very excited
about the show tonight.
Charlize Theron is here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Willie Nelson
is also our guest tonight.
Willie Nelson.
For appearing on the show,
we sent Willie
an edible arrangement.
[ Laughter ]
Not fruit -- it was
an arrangement of edibles.
And he likes gummies.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys,
in a speech last night,
former Vice President Mike Pence
made his clearest effort yet
to distance himself from Trump
by saying he was proud
to certify the election.
Wow.
It's a whole different side
of Pence.
[ Laughter ]
Next he says he wants to be
grand marshal
of the pride parade.
-I mean, it's amazing
what's happening to him.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Trump can't believe
Pence turned against him.
He was like, "Boy, just when
you think you know a guy
that you send an angry mob
into the Capitol building
to murder."
[ Laughter ]
Pence also tried to
lighten the mood
by telling a joke,
and he delivered it
as only Mike Pence can.
-There was this farmer
who decided to take his cow
to market.
So he loaded the cow
in the truck and the dog
and headed into town.
But on his way there,
there was a traffic accident.
Cow and the truck
went in one ditch,
and the farmer and dog
went in the other.
They ended up in court.
And the attorney for the other
driver was questioning,
"Isn't it true that you said you
never felt better in your life?"
He said, "Sir, would you like to
explain the circumstances
in which you made that comment?"
He said, "Yeah,
I reckon I would."
Me and the cow was in one ditch,
and the truck and dog
was in the other.
And I seen the sheriff,
and he walked over,
he looked down at that dog.
It had a broke back --
it wasn't going to get better.
He got his revolver out and
put it next to the dog's ear,
and he shot him.
And again, he mercifully
put his revolver
to the forehead of that cow
and pulled the trigger.
Then that sheriff walked over
to me and said,
"And how are you feeling?"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
The Pence was like,
"D-Darn, I told it wrong.
Let me try it again
from the top.
There was this farmer,
he was in a ditch."
What was that joke?
Seriously.
If you're looking to break up
your Fourth of July barbecue,
tell that one.
I mean, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Shooting the dog?
-Broken back.
-"Pulled his revolver out
and aimed at dog."
-"He wasn't gonna get
any better."
-It got worse
when the camera panned out
and it was just a group of
preschool kids.
And they go, "Oh."
Awful.
[ Laughter ]
Get this. According to
a new book coming out,
Trump made fun, apparently,
of Rudy Giuliani
for spitting during meetings.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
And even told him
that he sucked on TV.
[ Laughter ]
Spitting, sucking, sweating,
leaking --
he's like every awful guy
at Planet Fitness
rolled into one guy, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Rudy took it all
in stride, though.
He's like, "Look, he teases me,
but at the end of the day,
he also ruined my life."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, today,
Vice President Kamala Harris
made her first visit
to the U.S./Mexico border.
Yeah, she visited
the border town of El Paso.
Is it me or "El Paso" is not
the best name for a border town?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How about No Pass-O?
[ Applause ]
Some business news.
Popeyes just introduced
the new "I Don't Know" meal
for people who can't decide
what to order.
How can you be undecided
when the entire menu
has basically one thing?
[ Laughter ]
It's not like
customers are thinking,
"Should I have the fried
chicken or the, uh, sushi?
What do you think?
What do you think
I should have at Popeyes?"
[ Laughter ]
"How fresh are
the lobster tails?"
[ Laughter ]
Actually, they offer
the same meal at Arby's,
only it's the cook
who has no idea what's in it.
-Oh, there you go.
-"I don't know.
Uh, no, hey.
It's bleeding, whatever it is,
so I don't know.
It's something."
-"Yes, sir."
-And get this, astronomers
have identified
a "extremely eccentric
mini planet"
that just entered
our solar system,
and it's on course
to pass by Earth.
It's pretty exciting,
but we were curious what exactly
is an extremely
eccentric mini planet?
So here now
to talk about their trip
is the extremely
eccentric mini planet.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ British accent ]
Oh, my God.
Jimmy, I can't believe I'm here.
This is so random.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not too random.
We did invite you.
-Totally.
It's just that astronomers
are always telling me
I'm so eccentric.
You know, first they'll be like,
"Look at that normal planet
over there."
But then I'll be like, "Um,
I'm not like the other planets.
I'm a semi-amateur
craft cocktail mixologist."
Hello?
-Uh-huh.
So what exactly makes you
an eccentric planet?
-Well, my taste in music
is super-eclectic.
Like, sometimes I listen
to Lady Gaga,
but then sometimes
I listen to, like, a podcast.
It's like my mind
is on shuffle.
[ Laughter ]
-And that classifies you as an
extremely eccentric planet?
-Well, technically,
it's because I'm so small.
Because people --
people are always telling me
"Oh my gosh, Planet,
you're so fit."
And I'm like, "Um, you haven't
seen me on Taco Tuesday."
[ Laughs ]
-Well, maybe you could compare
and contrast yourself
with another planet.
-Sure.
So, like, Mars is red
and has a couple moons, right?
-Sure.
-Normal planet.
Whereas I collect
Funko Pop! figurines
and have a mustache tattoo
on my index finger.
Eccentric! Eccentric!
-Yeah, you're very eccentric.
I got it. I got it.
I got it.
Give me another example.
-Or, like, Earth has water
and can sustain life, right?
-Yeah.
-Normal planet.
Whereas I perform ukulele covers
of rap songs on Periscope.
Extremely eccentric.
-One last thing. That's not --
[ Chuckles ]
That's not --
That's not your
real accent, is it?
-[ American accent ]
No, it's completely fake.
-All right, good.
Thank you.
The extremely eccentric
mini planet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ] My gosh.
He's a-dork-ably eccentric.
-Yeah, a-dork-ably.
-And finally,
earlier this week,
police in Pennsylvania
broke up an exorcism
in the lumber aisle
of a Home Depot.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, an exorcism
in the lumber aisle.
Police laughed until
the 2x4 projectile vomited.
[ Laughter ]
Then they held a seance to
summon a being from far beyond,
a Home Depot employee.
"Does anyone work here?"
I want to quickly mention
the Miley Cyrus concert
on Peacock.
It's out now, too.
It's awesome, by the way.
So check it out, yeah, if you're
a fan of music in general.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's on Peacock. She crushes.
We love you, Miley.
And I wanted to give another
shout-out to The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look what I received.
Look what I received today.
Oh, la, la, Sasson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-You released a deluxe version
of "Do You Want More?!!!??!"
This is your second album.
Is this correct?
-Yeah, second, but our
major label debut.
Our second album.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It comes with
a booklet in here.
It comes with four
super 180 gram vinyls.
Look at this jam.
Come on, you don't mess around.
When The Roots do something,
they do it right.
Look at this guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love the pictures in here.
I love the stories in here.
I want to show a picture
of Quest and Tariq.
Look at these.
-Babies.
-Look at these kids.
-Aww.
-[ Laughs ]
-They're like, we're going to be
on "The Tonight Show"
one day with Jimmy Fallon.
Yeah.
You know what I found
interesting in this
is the whole story
about you signing for Geffen
and how Rich --
Richard was like,
"Dude, I don't know.
They might drop you guys."
-Yeah, the last minute,
we decided to exile to the UK
and live there for like four --
what, three to four years
almost?
On and off, touring?
-Yeah.
-Was this the record that
kind of broke the band open?
Like, this is --
-Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely.
-This was it?
-That was it.
-The one after this
was "Illadelph--"
-"Illadelph Halflife."
Yeah, and then yeah.
-That's my favorite,
but I'll tell you,
hey, what are you gonna do?
But I love
"Do You Want More?!!!??!"
And the title,
is that based off the track,
which based off the Arsenio
Hall thing, or no?
-Yeah, we happened to see
Arsenio had his version
of, like --
it was like Letterman's
human tricks thing?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stupid human tricks?
-Yeah. Well, we saw jazz great
playing bagpipes.
-Rufus Harley.
-Rufus Harley. Yeah.
-Yeah.
He played bagpipes?
-We saw him on "Arsenio Hall,"
and he happened to be
in Philadelphia.
So we looked him up
in the White Pages,
if you remember
what the White Pages were.
-Yeah, of course
I remember the White Pages.
-They still make
the White Pages?
-The White Pages, great.
And you found him
in the White Pages?
-Yeah, we did.
-Not in the Yellow Pages.
-Rufus Harley.
-Just under his name,
and you got him
over to the studio.
-He didn't believe us.
-Were you the first --
-We had to have cash in hand
immediately
as soon as he got to the studio.
-Were you the first hip-hop
group to ever have a bagpiper?
-Yes.
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
-[ Laughs ] I love it.
And then it turned out
to be the title.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Well, you know I love vinyl,
so I appreciate this.
And congrats, Roots.
This is -- Check this out.
If you love music, get this.
"Do You Want More?!!!??!"
Deluxe Edition.